the deal comes after six
weeks of relentless fighting it was
first announced in a facebook post by
armenian prime minister
nicole pacinian within minutes
confirmation came from azerbaijan
in moscow
on november 9th the president of
azerbaijan the prime minister of armenia
and president of russian federation
signed a statement which declares the
complete ceasefire and military action
in the nagorno-karabakh war zone
starting from midnight of november 10th
moscow time
armenia's prime minister described the
deal as unbelievably painful
[Music]
the backlash against him was immediate
moments after the announcement furious
demonstrators stormed into the
parliament in yerevan to protest the
decision
the conflict they argue is about much
more than land
but armenia had undergone a number of
defeats
just hours before azeri forces overran
agora kharaba second city
shoe shot they were on the road to the
capital when the deal was signed
the prospect of conflict and its
cost could be so much worse for the
armenians given the current rate of
momentum
more than a thousand people on both
sides have died
tens of thousands are now displaced
the region is within azerbaijan but has
been under the control of ethnic
armenians since 1994.
decades of tension and violence have
followed
while an agreement has been signed to
end the war
it's unlikely it will also end the
animosity between the two countries
russian forces are already being
deployed to keep
the peace katya lopez of the yan
al jazeera